son 120 nuevos casos que sumados a los
63 del día anterior convierten este
rebrote de hebei en el mayor de china en
los últimos 5 meses las autoridades
locales han dictado y al protocolo
habitual han ordenado el cerrojo sobre
la capital provincial han cancelado
vuelos y trenes y cerrado escuelas y
guarderías también han ordenado que se
empiecen a practicar tests sobre toda la
población unos 11 millones de habitantes
esa era la estrategia que china solía
tomar con los primeros rebrotes después
adoptó medidas más quirúrgicas con tests
sólo en los distritos afectados y ahora
hay recuperado esa estrategia primero
por el altísimo número de contagios para
los parámetros chinos y segundo por la
proximidad con beijing aquí en la
capital hay medidas de seguridad
reforzadas en las tiendas vuelven a
pedir la mascarilla los bares y
restaurantes vuelven a tomar la
temperatura y exigir el código verde que
en el móvil indica que uno no ha estado
en lugares peligrosos y además china ha
endurecido los requisitos de entrada
desde el exterior a las dos semanas de
confinamiento obligatorio en hoteles
ahora se ha añadido una tercera que el
recién llegado tendrá que pasar en casa